President Trump is expected to decertify
the Iran nuclear deal that president
slammed the agreement as one-sided last
night in a Fox News interview I think it
was one of the most incompetent lead Ron
deals I've ever seen a hundred and fifty
billion dollars given we got nothing
we got nothing it's a horrible horrible
embarrassment to our country weakness
when actually we had great strength
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with what des certifying the agreement
means for its future Margaret good
morning good morning well the president
will unveil a number of actions to crack
down on Iran but he will not tear up
that nuclear deal instead he's putting
it in serious jeopardy by giving
Congress the power to decide whether to
reimpose sanctions on Iran by doing so
he is rejecting the advice of his top
national security advisors who point to
US intelligence that show Iran is
abiding by the nuclear agreement but the
administration wants to write a new law
that no longer requires the president to
regularly certify that doing so in the
past has infuriated President Trump and
led to arguments with Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson the administration also
wants to threaten new sanctions to on
Iran in order to get a new round of
diplomacy to address the problems that
mr. Trump seized including demands for
more inspections and a plan for what
happens when the existing deal expires
in ten years now all of this allows the
president to say he delivered on a
campaign promise to get tough on Iran
but it risks conflict with that country
Nora and alienating us partners in
Europe Russia and China alright great
reporting Margaret thank you so much